[Musica]
pensate appunto a due che si conoscono
maschio e una femmina e si parlano e
iniziano a piacersi sono diversi però
hanno voglia di parlarsi e hanno voglia
di pensare al futuro hanno voglia di
scambiarsi le loro esperienze sono due
maturi Eh non sono due ragazzini
perché in realtà lo sport e l'impresa
sono diversi sono diversi non
diversissimi ma sono diversi l'impresa
nasce come un'attività economica a volte
al profitto lo scambio di beni lo sport
per fare risultati agonistici almeno
all'inizio chi lavora nell'impresa più
avanti negli anni più fa carriera più
diventa capace nello sforzo soprattutto
per quanto riguarda gli atleti questo
non è vero E
nello sport ci vogliono capacità
cognitive motorie nelle imprese le
capacità cognitive sono sicuramente
prevalenti e nello sport è molto
visibile la parte diciamo di
responsabilità di valore sociale mentre
nell'impresa bisogna Insomma lavorarci
un pochettino
se parliamo di sport parliamo di
un'attività un media globale
straordinario parliamo di un'attività
che è in grado di coagulare in grado di
far stare vicini di fare appassionare al
di là di quelle che sono le religioni al
di là di quelle che sono le ideologie
parliamo di un'attività da un punto di
vista educativo straordinario perché
i bambini e le bambine che fanno Sport
migliorano le loro qualità di vita e
stanno più lontani dai comportamenti a
rischio se lo sport È fatto bene di
fatto lo sport è un fatto culturale
perché produce segni simboli produce
informazioni genera contenuti genera
oggetti spesso volti al bene a volte
anche avvolti non propriamente a
comportamenti diciamo positivi devianti
e quindi più si va avanti più lo sport è
complesso e quindi che cosa può
cominciamo
dall'impresa cosa può l'impresa
chiedere al suo partner cosa può
insegnare Beh innanzitutto questa
complessità richiede una buona
organizzazione
un'organizzazione che deve essere sempre
crescente quindi
la parte che lo sport deve ascoltare
dell'impresa è sicuramente
l'aspetto manageriale la cultura
manageriale Quindi di cosa dovrà parlare
l'impresa allo sport cosa potrà dirgli
potrà parlargli di organigramma dovrà
parlare di modelli dovrà parlare di
controllo di gestione dovrà parlare di
organizzazione e
Diciamo che
dovrà ricordare è il valore di quello
che lo sport può fare il valore del suo
prodotto Quindi parlare di marketing di
comunicazione Magari anche di profitto
in cui lo sport non è propriamente e non
è propriamente il suo forte ma
soprattutto
[Musica]
l'impresa dovrà parlare del futuro
perché la capacità strategica è quella
che in questo momento veramente manca lo
sport manca la capacità di pensare al
futuro la capacità di ragionare per
obiettivi a lungo lungo termine nello
sport nessuno si chiede perché Facciamo
sport Dove andiamo A cosa serve questa
cosa è una cosa che non accade Questa è
una cosa che veramente dalle imprese noi
dobbiamo dobbiamo assolutamente imparare
E invece lo sport che cosa può
che cosa può chiedere in qualche modo
che cosa può raccontare all'impresa Beh
intanto
vi devo dire che
c'è tanta letteratura su questi aspetti
e soprattutto una cosa è stata molto
evidente che noi dobbiamo cercare di
capire sostanzialmente Che tipo di sport
andiamo a guardare se siamo un'impresa
perché ogni sport è parecchio diverso
soprattutto se noi in qualche modo
dobbiamo cercare non dico dei modelli
organizzativi e qualcosa però che
riguardi alcuni aspetti
dell'organizzazione Nel modo con cui fa
è una squadra Nel modo con cui si gioca
in uno sport perché Vedete se noi
andiamo abbiamo una situazione Diciamo
in qualche modo
legata a per esempio un interdipendenza
molto forte
fra i membri di un team un
interdipendenza che è anche un
interdipendenza che porta ad esempio a
fare in modo che sia contestuale cioè
sequenziale quindi cioè quello che fa un
membro del team alla fine si impatta
immediatamente su quello che fanno sul
risultato su anche sul risultato di
tutti Ecco se noi abbiamo un'impresa
così non dobbiamo cercare andare a
cercare uno sport tipo il Baseball dove
ognuno fa il suo in maniera molto
slegato dobbiamo cercare uno sport tipo
il Baseball tipo il volley questa poca
attenzione nei confronti di questo
aspetto ha fatto sì che non sempre ci
fossero dei risultati positivi in questo
modo che ha
l'impresa di guardare allo sport
e però ci sono delle cose di cui
oggettivamente
Sport impresa questi due fidanzati si
possono si possono parlare C'è un
argomento su cui alla fine
tutti devono ascoltare nessuna qualcosa
da insegnare all'altro che riguarda la
leadership riguarda la Team leadership
cosa per cui si guarda molto allo sport
ma in realtà chi studia tanto su questo
aspetto sono le imprese sono le char c'è
tantissimo C'è tanta letteratura è poca
sostanza non ci sono ancora delle delle
vere certezze ma perché in qualche modo
lo sport potrebbe essere interessante o
è interessante perché nello sport c'è
una sorta di immediatezza nella gestione
del team l'immediatezza è data dal fatto
che il risultato si vede subito parliamo
ad esempio dell'allenatore il risultato
si vede subito
nella gara quindi e soprattutto è
estremamente Palese si vince si perde
tutto il mondo ti guarda quindi questo
rende di fatto alcuni aspetti della Team
leadership degli Allenatori e dello
Sport interessanti per chi fa un'impresa
perché è come se gli allenatori avessero
dovuto nel tempo trovare degli
aggiustamenti molto forti e molto
potenti per questi per questi aspetti
e se da una parte però accade che
l'ottimizzazione organizzativa è
sicuramente tema dell'impresa e che lo
sport deve guardare all'impresa rispetto
a questi temi quella parte invece che
riguarda la motivazione e invece una
parte in cui davvero lo sport può fare
diversamente e può davvero insegnare
qualcosa all'impresa perché
la motivazione non monetaria Cioè nel
senso di dire fai questa cosa che ti
è un fatto che ti arriverà un bonus
quello che è la motivazione che non
riguarda questi aspetti che sono degli
aspetti se volete un po' personali degli
aspetti legati al momento degli aspetti
che di quelle attività che le persone
mettono in atto nel momento in cui
stanno facendo qualcosa quindi non so vi
sto parlando di attenzione vi sto
parlando di coscienziosità vi sto
parlando di resilienza eh tutti questi
aspetti sono aspetti che in qualche modo
lo sport riesce a motivare attraverso
delle strategie Ma poi adesso vi dirò
perché è più facile motivare nello sport
queste questa parte delle
questa parte del nostro del nostro agire
quindi lo sport riesce a motivare in
maniera in maniera particolare e perché
lo sport riesce a motivarlo diversamente
e riesce a motivarlo meglio perché nello
sport alla fine
tutto quello che accade si può ed è
strettamente collegato in realtà ai
valori e questa è una cosa su cui poi
diventa facile far lavorare le persone
perché il valore esplicitato il valore
condiviso
ti aiuta a capire bene dove sei e per
cosa stai lavorando Ti aiuta a capire il
contesto questo vale anche per i bambini
abbiamo sentito parlare prima di Skills
abbiamo sentito e sono
straordinariamente importanti l'attività
sportiva ben fatta migliora le skill
migliora la capacità dei bambini e delle
bambine migliora la loro capacità di
inserirsi in un contesto sociale e
questo miglior inserimento si atto
attraverso i valori se voi esprimete e
chiarite in qualche modo i valori con
cui governate anche una semplice società
sportiva i bambini e le bambine che
lavorano con voi ma vi dico anche gli
atleti e gli atleti delle delle squadre
che fanno la serie A capiscono per cosa
stanno facendo questa cosa e hanno
un'interpretazione di tutto quello che
accade Certo che i valori devono essere
chiari devono essere comunicati ma
soprattutto
bisogna starci attenti vanno sempre
sempre testimoniati e non vanno
testimoniate attraverso
sostanzialmente le parole ma vanno
testimoniate attraverso i fatti
quindi se noi saremo in grado di far
funzionare questo matrimonio fra impresa
e sport di fare in modo che gli atleti
le prime squadre gli atleti più
piccolini riescano in qualche maniera ad
avere delle skill migliori rispetto a
quelle che sono quelle che hanno non
hanno i bambini che non fanno attività
sportiva andremo sicuramente ad
impattare su quello che è il valore su
quello che è il nostro capitale umano
Quindi questo è un matrimonio che
va fatto assolutamente perché è vero che
c'è la scuola ma l'attività sportiva sia
che sia che riguardi quello che noi
vediamo quello che trasmettono le nostre
prime squadre quindi valori che
trasmettono le nostre prime squadre sia
quello che invece
facciamo praticamente insegnando lo
sport ai bambini e facendo in modo che
abbiano un'esperienza positiva Ecco
questo impatto sul capitale umano ed è
da questo punto di vista irrinunciabile
Quindi io spero molto in un matrimonio
felice perché abbiamo bisogno di ambedue
siamo ancora però un po' indietro grazie
[Applauso]